uh a bunch of people requested that i
talk about this
stupid [ __ ] the hyper port and yeah
i do agree that this thing is
cripplingly stupid like i mean if only
if you just look at the website
it has all the characteristics with
[ __ ] vaporware about it like the
shiny cgi images and the over promise
all this
corporate [ __ ] about what like a new
mode of transport that offers many
benefits
and a convincing basic concept i think
your [ __ ] alarm should be going off
right there and there
but guys here's the thing though i don't
want to turn my channel into a [ __ ]
24 7
non-stop elon musk dunk fest okay i feel
like i've talked enough about elon musk
so far
but wait what is this alright boys and
girls
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is the hyper port it's hyperloop
but for containers
and it's really [ __ ] stupid for
reasons i'll be explaining this is a
clear continuation of this sort of
techno [ __ ]
fake futurism griff that has been
ongoing for the past 10 to 15 years
and the process is as follows take
something that works and has a good
economy of scale and is efficient etc
take it apart into small inefficient
pieces make the pieces look like
futuristic
sex toys and then start calling them
pods and this is how innovation works
since 2010.
it's essentially the aesthetic of
futurism and innovation whereby these
quote unquote innovators try to increase
speed at the cost of everything else
such as capacity safety reliability
because hey who cares if your system is
cripplingly inefficient and
horribly unsafe and only has a fraction
of the capacity of a regular system as
long as big brain epic bacon scienceman
on twitter says that it will go
bigly fast and that's exactly what's
happening with the hyper port
except for elon musk who's not involved
thankfully so the concept itself has a
variety of crippling problems
and some of them might actually sound
familiar to you from my previous
hyperloop video
check it out if you haven't yet such as
trying to build a huge near vacuum
chamber
the ultra high speed and its
consequences the cost obviously
and of course the use of pods and
there's also a
mystery problem which i'll just be
teasing for now and explain later
so first off the near vacuum in general
the bigger the vacuum chamber the harder
it is to maintain
so you know if you ever wondered why you
don't see around any vacuum trains
nowadays despite having been invented in
1904
well that's why the theory is intuitive
and easy to understand
but putting it into practice is a
different story and so on the animation
we see these cute little doors opening
on the top of the pods
and i'll just chalk it up to cg [ __ ]
because the doors will need to be some
real heavy duty things
able to keep the pods pressurized even
in an air vacuum and yes the pods will
need to be pressurized because not all
goods can withstand a near vacuum
the next major problem of the hyper port
is the high speed
now you might be asking why is high
speed a problem well high speed itself
is not a problem
its consequences are high speeds in this
case 600 kilometers per hour requires
super straight tracks
now that means you will most likely not
be able to use existing right-of-way
such as roads and railroads
i.e a ton of costly land purchases along
the way and that means
nimbies lawsuits people blocking
construction
so basically an absolute nightmare and
since they plan on having this thing cut
through
germany for the most part anyway this
would mean trying to draw a mostly
straight line through a very dense web
of settlements
because as it turns out europe is not
like nevada let's say where you can just
start out in a straight line and then
not hit a human settlement for 3 000
kilometers
just the easements and the lawsuits are
alone enough to wreck this entire
project
and so the next big issue with the hyper
port is of course the use of pods
and it seems to me that point one a on
any technical [ __ ] drifters list is
break up a functioning large scale
system into small individual units for
no reason
we had subways now we have individual
underground pods we had high speed
trains now we have individual vacuum
passenger pods and now it's the freight
train's turn to become an individual
vacuum cargo pod but of course these
visionaries quote-unquote are not
allowed to hook the pots together for a
better economy of scale
because that would look too much like a
train and we can't have that so
according to the promotional video the
system can move
2 800 containers on a single line system
and this number is per day a single line
so is it like
one direction or both oh here we go on
the hyperloop tt website
the system can move two thousand eight
hundred containers a day in an enclosed
operating environment and remember
okay so this is both directions so this
means the capacity of the system will be
1
400 containers per day per direction
which is 58 containers per hour which is
conveniently around one container per
minute
so how does this measure up to a
conventional rail system as in a freight
train carrying containers
so if we take a freight train with let's
say 40 containers on it which is
quite usual and we let one go every 12
minutes from the port that's 5 trains
per hour
that adds up to 200 containers per hour
or 3.3 containers per minute
so this means that regular freight
trains have more than three times the
capacity as the hyper port and we are
assuming dedicated freight tracks
because if a port would be important
enough to consider a hyper report in it
it is important enough to have dedicated
freight tracks already so you know
but wait there's more what if we figure
out an innovative system which lets us
run trains every 8 minutes instead of
12.
that would mean we'll be able to run 7
freight trains per hour in a direction
which is 280 containers per hour which
is 4.66 containers per minute
more than four times the capacity of the
hyper port and if we want to go
absolutely crazy because this is the
future we can have quadruple tracks
which means two tracks in each direction
that means a capacity of 9.33 containers
per minute
more than nine times the capacity of the
hyper port
meaning that if we wanted our future
tech to keep up with two
tracks of conventional railway we would
need to stack around
ten tubes on top of each other so we are
left with a system which is
fast and that's about it you know kind
of like google chrome
but then the hamburg port's website goes
on to say unlike the transportation of
people
the focus of hyperloop cargo solutions
is not on speed but rather on the
greatest possible throughput transport
units per hour and on low energy
transport
what okay so if the focus is not on
speed but on
throughput then why not just do away
with the vacuum chamber and the pods
because that's
clearly a bottleneck and so why not just
link all the pots together into one
gigapod chain and then run them across
the country on the existing rail network
and
[Music]
so if your focus is not
on speed but rather on capacity
then why don't you build
a train
but yeah no this is [ __ ] speed is
clearly a very important selling point
slash consideration and i'm going to
continue with that in mind
so the hyper port also promises to
reclaim valuable waterfront property and
move the ports inland okay so in cargo
ports a lot of space is taken up by
having to actually store the containers
a container ship comes in you offload
the containers onto this gigantic
concrete plot
and you keep them there until you can
load them on a freight train or a truck
so we can assume that it's the storage
part that they want to move inland
so when a container ship comes in
instead of having to store the
containers on the waterfront
they get loaded directly into the
hyperport which takes them to this
inland port
meaning that the huge container depots
would be there so if they want to free
up space on the coastline they would
need just a single berth where ships can
mower
and then right next to it some kind of a
streamlined loading mechanism which puts
the containers directly inside the
hyperboard
because that's how you can get rid of
the gigantic container depots
okay so a modern triple e class
container ship can hold around
20 000 containers and we want to unload
all that into the hyper port without any
sort of depot so once again we're
loading directly so we are constrained
by the hyper port's capacity which is
one container per minute
and this number will be the same even if
we have some kind of ultra fast crane
mechanism because i presume that you
need to have some space between the pods
as they travel in the tube because of
course we have to run them individually
instead of hooking them together because
that would look too much like a train
and we cannot have
that so normally using conventional
methods even the biggest cargo ships can
be unloaded in like two or three days
maximum
but if we go with the hyper port and its
inland port direct loading solution
unloading a ship with 20 000 containers
would take
two entire weeks meaning that your ports
will need to stay on the waterfront they
will not move inland
so this selling point is just complete
[ __ ] and so at the end of the day
what we are left with
is a vacuum tube system connecting all
these european major logistics hubs so
from a logistics chain perspective
nothing really changes drastically the
only difference is that now we have this
sort of
oversized pneumatic post system next to
our existing highways and tracks but hey
that could work right at least
some containers could get from say
frankfurt to paris real fast
but despite its high speed would the
system be viable at
all well turns out in logistics speed is
not the end all be all
i mean granted it's a very easily
marketable metric able to induce the soy
face in your average reddit user in two
milliseconds but turns out that
logistics companies have somewhat
different expectations
and here's a quote from a gentleman
called clifton wesselsian who is a
managing director
sourcing and purchasing transform
some kind of clergyman italics partners
he says an
unforeseen disruption in just one piece
of a linear supply chain can have a
devastating financial impact on the
entire system
just as a physical chain is only as
strong as its weakest link
so basically logistics companies are
much more concerned about reliability
and consistency than sheer speed and so
how does the hyper port stack up when it
comes to these considerations
not too well as it turns out you know
the good thing about freight trade is
that it's reliable and flexible if a
line gets clogged up because of some
kind of accident other freight trains
can be routed around the area thus
minimizing the potential losses
now if the hyper report breaks down
somewhere on the way say halfway between
frankfurt and paris if you want to fix
the problem
you need to evacuate the entire route so
the distance is about
480 kilometers which the pods
conveniently cover in 48 minutes at 600
kilometers per hour so there's one pot
every minute meaning that at any given
time there are 48 pods on the way per
direction
so if a pod breaks down halfway that
means it'll have 23 others stuck behind
it
so you will need to send in a towing
vehicle from paris but before you can do
that you have to wait for all the posts
to come out which will take around 24
minutes
and then you have to travel back with
the towing vehicle to the broken pot
which will take 24 minutes again
and then you have to hook it up somehow
i have no idea how because these spots
don't seem to have any coupling
mechanisms so let's assume that it will
take around
10 minutes to hook up the broken part
remotely and then the actual towing out
of the vehicle will happen at say half
speed at 300 kilometers per hour for
safety reasons this will be another
48 minutes so at this point we'll have
spent around
90 minutes cleaning up the mess and that
means we have 90 pods stuck behind us
so this means the unloading mechanism
plus the airlock cycle will have to work
significantly faster than 60 seconds per
pod
otherwise they will not be able to work
down the pile up and if during this
insane twice to speed disaster operation
something else happens say an airlock
malfunctions because of the heavy load
that would mean yet another possibly
longer shutdown meaning
an even bigger disruption and thus even
higher losses welcome to a new era of
reliability i guess
not to mention there is such a thing as
reverse branching
meaning that a breakdown in one section
of the system can cause holdups in
completely unrelated sections
for example if a hundred pods pile up
towards paris for some reason that's 100
pods less in the other parts of the
system
assuming that the pods upon delivering a
container would be circulated back
immediately in order to increase
efficiency
so basically all hubs will need to stock
enough additional pots to resist a major
failure on one of those sections
in this case the paris hub would need to
release 100 fresh pods into the system
to keep up the capacity but if the
breakdown is more severe and say 300
parts queue up towards paris that means
paris now has to release 300 new pods
and all these additional pods are
additional points of failure
meaning that the more pods you have to
store run or maintain the more chance
you will have for a breakdown
right so as you can see the hyper port
is not the paragon of reliability
the problems i brought up so far are
already bad enough so bad that they can
kill this entire idea before anyone even
touches a shovel
but there's one more specific problem
that i want to talk about
the mystery problem a problem so severe
that i could have just began this video
with it and then that would have been
the end of it it's like we are
paramedics going to the scene of a car
crash we prepare to treat the victim and
we go through their injuries
multiple bruises broken bones
lacerations oh and their head is missing
that would be the equivalent of the
problem so already
[Music]
it'll be extremely easy to sabotage this
system and so let's take a geopolitical
rival such as the russian government
after assassinating a political opponent
in berlin in broad daylight or poisoning
a former agent and his daughter in
salisbury or blowing up ammunition
depots in the czech republic what if
they decide that they next want to
sabotage a major western logistics
artery and the problem is that with the
hyperport by nature of its concept it
will be extremely easy
for example what if you have an agent
sneaking to the maintenance depot or
something in a maintenance worker outfit
and
mess with the electronics of a few pods
to cause them to break down later to
cause delays and losses
actually you wouldn't even need to sneak
into the maintenance facilities you can
just smuggle some explosives into a
container which is to be shipped by the
pods and then remote detonated midway if
the explosion manages to blow a hole
into the tube you're going to have a
column of one atmosphere air rushing
in running into that a tree near vacuum
will be like hitting a brick wall
so this would wreck multiple pods along
the way before they can stop which would
likely cause damage to the pipes in
further sections
fixing all this damage would take months
and millions of years if not hundreds of
millions
not to mention the enormous losses
incurred after having your logistics
article
shut down for multiple weeks so in
practice this would mean that all
containers will need to be carefully
screened before loading them into the
pods
which means additional costs staff
infrastructure and delays
but even then instead of putting the
explosives into the container
the agents can just blow up one of the
pillars or something or just shoot a big
enough gun at the pipe
both of these would immediately result
in a vacuum failure with the same
results as before
but hell maybe you won't even need any
specialized equipment such as guns or
bombs
turns out that fertilizer as in ammonium
nitrate can also do a decent job
and since the hyper port is cutting
through you know agricultural fields
mostly
your cover would be perfect you could
drop a hundred tons of fertilizer below
the pipes and no one would bet an
eye not to mention your incredibly easy
access to the materials
and if you think that the secret agent
plot is a bit too far-fetched hey maybe
it won't be the fsb
maybe it will be isis militants or any
other domestic terrorist
the main point is that this system would
be horrendously vulnerable to all
kinds of sabotage in contrast if you
blow up a container on a regular train
you won't be able to cause
that much damage even if you somehow
manage to turn part of the tracks into a
crater or something it won't be that
difficult to fix
meanwhile other freight trains would
just get rerouted thus minimizing losses
and delays
with the hyperport though this would
just not be possible and for countries
and major logistics companies
this is where the story ends and look
speed is a very nice thing
everybody wants to go br but not at any
cost
states and logistics companies do want a
very fast delivery system
but not at the cost of reliability
safety
capacity and flexibility among other
things
and i find it amazing really that
hyperloop tt managed to
grift their way into germany of all
places and i think this will go the
usual way
meaning first off we get the shiny cgi
and then some photo ops with some
bizarre smiles
and then that's going to be pretty much
it you know even if the hyper port was
viable engineering wise and safety wise
or capacity wise even
that would still not be a guarantee that
it would get built because turns out
major infrastructure projects are a bit
more complicated than
i saw a pretty cgi video on twitter so
i'm just going to call it now
i don't think the hyper port will ever
be put into operation
and even if by some miracle it will get
built somehow
it'll take about a week for a
catastrophic failure or some sabotage to
happen
so the hyper port dumb idea just like
the hyperloop
just like pods in general and you know
if you really really really insist on
some kind of futuristic cargo solution
then why not just build a maglab or
something as i was making this video
china actually came out with a new model
of maglev that can do the same speed as
the hyper port
so you know at this point why not just
build a maglev track connecting all
these major logistics hubs
it would still be somewhat dumb but hey
at least you could get rid of the near
vacuum tube
but hey don't take my word for all this
i'm just some random dude on youtube
making videos
and i'm up against these genius
visionaries with years and years of
experience
who are about to revolutionize logistics
i'm joking of course
every single thing about this project is
dumb and this should be obvious for
anyone with even a cursory understanding
of our reality
so hyper port bad meme and i hope to
never see it again in my life
in the meantime thank you very much for
watching and please like and subscribe
and don't forget to check out my patreon
if you think this content is worth your
money and i'll be seeing you
next time
you